bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 78
de l'été nous allons vous donner 1 et
une idée pour réussir votre été à
Saint-Quentin tout à fait Alice c'est un
78 de l'été un peu vert puisque nous
allons tout à l'heure aller à l'Espace
Rambouillet pour découvrir toutes les
activités proposées tout au long de
l'été mais sans plus attendre on vous
retrouve à la base de loisir c'est
parti nous sommes à la base de loisirs
de 50 ans en Eveline qui propose durant
tout l'été de nombreuses activités mais
aussi des événements incontournable que
nous allons découvrir avec Frédéric
border directeur de la base de
loisir Frédéric Bordier bonjour bonjour
nous sommes à la base nautique de la
base de loisirs derrière nous le plan
d'eau qui fait plus de 100 hactares 120
120 hear exactement sur lequel on voit
des catamarans des dériveurs des
optimistes donc ce sont des activités
qu'on va pouvoir faire tout au long de
l'été é alors tout au long de l'été oui
avec les planches à voile bien sûr avec
le canoué avec effectivement de la voile
traditionnelle laser optimiste pour les
classes de découvert pour les centres de
loisir parce qu'on est encore en période
scolaire qui enfin la période scolaire
vient de se terminer et nous rentrons
dans une période de vacances où on
espère avoir un peu de soleil et du vent
en tout cas pour pour la voile alors on
va retrouver les activités classiques de
la base de loisir mais avant cela on va
parler des événements qui vont jalonner
tout l'été à commencer par le village
sportif oui alors le village sportif
c'est une opération nouvelle pour la
base de loisir puisqu'elle a été mis en
place une première fois sur une autre
base de loisir qui est vert torsi et
cette année trois bases de loisirs sont
associé à l'opération donc 150 jeunes
vont se retrouver autour d'un village à
l'intérieur de la piscine àague où ils
vont pouvoir pratiquer capoera tir à
l'arc cémateur de glisse équitation
voile piscine bien sûr j'en oublie enfin
une quantité d'activités Sportiv BO tout
est gratuit il suffit simplement de
réserver auprès de lufolet qui est notre
partenaire officielle et tout est
gratuit alors outre ce village sportif
on retrouve on va retrouver aussi des
activités autour de la piscine à vague
oui piscine vague donc Beach au soleil
donc vous savez qu'à l'intérieur de la
piscine depuis plusieurs années on
essaie de de un peu varier nos nos
activités et donc on a mis en place un
beach un beach volet un beach rugby un
sandbal à l'intérieur de la piscine on a
aussi également devant la piscine de
simulateur de Gliss donc la vague de
surf vous avez sûrement dû entendre
parler voilà donc qui à l'origine aurait
dû être à l'intérieur de la piscine qui
se trouve à l'extérieur de la piscine
c'est un gros appareil avec une vague de
surf on peut faire du surf ou du body
surf et pour toutes les activités Beach
volet et cetera il faut s'inscrire à
l'avance alors pour le Beach volet
l'intérieur de la piscine il suffit de
payer la l'entrée de la piscine et puis
après tout est gratuit à l'intérieur
mais ça coûte la piscine à vague on va
dire entre 4,70 € et et 6 € c'est en
fonction de si on a une famille seule et
justement le public on retrouve plutôt
des familles ou des jeunes en entre
l'été beaucoup beaucoup de groupes sur
la semaine et le weekend bien sûr
famille alors une autre activité que
vous proposez c'est le cinéma en plein
air oui on a déjà commencé par un cinéma
de pleinire le le 7 juillet sur une
opération 3D et là le 25 août on se
retrouve autour de Buena Vista Social
Club les célèbres musiciens cubains
exactement et donc à l'intérieur de la
piscine avec une nocturne piscine on se
ben jusqu'à 9h30 et après on passe au
film et alors les activités vont
s'étendre jusqu'en septembre oui on a
une opération qu'on renouvelle cette
année qui s'appelle sentez-vous bien
sentez-vous sport toujours en
partenariat avec la région et des
villages sportifs ça va de la box de la
marge nordique enfin plein de surprises
avec un gros partenariat d'associations
le
crosif énormément de d'associations
locales qui vont effectivement proposer
des activités sportif pendant 2 jours
sensibiliser les gens donc à la pratique
du sport et pouvoir permettre à
certaines personnes peut-être de
s'inscrire pour suivre des activités
toute l'année à la base ah oui de toute
façon toutes nos activités sont un point
d'initiation vers la pratique
continuelle euh de l'activité sportive
alors outre tous ces événements qui vont
enrichir l'été à la base de loisir de
saintcentin en Yveline on retrouve aussi
les grands classiques alors on peut
parler de l'acrobranche l'acrobranche
bien sûr un grand classique toujours
pareil toujours la question de se
renouvel donc on a des des nouveaux
ateliers qui ont été mis en place on a
la ligne de vie continue qui permet en
fait de de de tout au long de jamais se
décrocher donc accessible à des des plus
jeunes donc ça c'est pas inintéressant
c'est-à-dire quel âge euh on va dire
pour les premir on a qu on a cinq
parcours le parcours sous filet pour les
tout petits tout petits hein les les
maternels et après on a du parcours vert
jusqu'au parcours noir comme au ski et
en fonction de la taille on ne sait pas
c'est pas la la la compétence le niveau
c'est la taille qui fait qu'on peut
aller ou pas sur un parcours de plus en
plus costaud alors la base de loisir de
50 ans en Eveline il y a aussi des
animaux à commencer par le club équestre
ah le club équestre oui on a une 50
desquidé donc effectivement toute
l'année des stages des concours du
baptême poney du poney game et cetera et
cetera donc de nombreuses activités
liées à la pratique du cheval même si on
dit équitation et aussi la ferme
pédagogique ferme pédagogique premier
service pédagogique comme son nom
l'indique qui accueille sur des ateliers
ça va de de l'abeille au pain au fromage
mais aussi à la simplement à la visite
guidée de la ferme avec cette année une
particularité on a ouvert une boutique
on peut acheter du miel on peut acheter
des œufs on peut acheter des souvenirs
enfin plein de petites choses comme ça
sur la ferme alors il y a aussi un golf
sur cette base oui un golf qui est en
concession et c'est Blue Green qui gère
le golf donc 45 trous hein donc le plus
grand golf de la région parisienne et
donc on y pratique toute l'année
différents parcours et stage alors on
peut aussi venir tout l'été simplement
pour s'allonger sur la pelouse et
profiter du soleil est-ce qu'on a le
droit drit de faire des barbecue des
piquequ alors ce qui est bien sûr qu'on
a on a le droit de venir se balader déjà
on a le droit de venir profiter observer
regarder simplement on a la réserve
naturelle qui est un espace privilégié
on peut observer les oiseaux 230 espèces
d'oiseaux différents on peut venir
piqueniquer forcément on peut venir
barbecuter alors c'est toléré on dit on
dit pas que c'est autorisé parce que il
y a il y a des consignes de
sécurité dur donc c'est une pratique
très courante comme tout le monde le
sait au mois de mai au mois de juin
quand il fait beau la base est remplie
remplie de de gens qui viennent
piquniquer c'est un peu leur jardin pour
des gens qui n'ont pas forcément la
chance d'avoir un petit jardin chez eux
vous attendez combien de personnes pour
cet été pour l'été j'en sais rien on a à
peu près on aime bien dire don qu'on
franchit les 1 million sur l'année mais
on a des weekends qui peuvent monter
jusqu'à 50 60 voire 70000 personnes sur
le weekend alors sur un été je sais pas
200 300 300000 personnes est-ce que
parfois au niveau de la sécurité c'est
difficile à gérer ah oui le problème de
sécurité est un gros problème sur la
base de loisir non pas qu'il y ait
beaucoup de vandalisme mais
effectivement ce quand on a accueil
énormément de voitures on peut à un
moment donné se poser la question si on
va pas fermer la base comme le weekend
de la pente-côte ou le dimanche le deuxè
jour et ben on s'est vraiment posé la
question de savoir si on allait fermer
ou pas la la base à oisir 1h30 pour
rentrer sur la base du côté trappe là ça
me permet d'insister sur le fait qu'il
existe une une entrée au nord de la base
vers sur la paix céleste qui d'ailleurs
va être valorisé dans le cadre des
travaux du Vélodrome et qui est très peu
connu de la population et donc 70 % des
gens passent par trap et 30 % seulement
sur Montini donc ça nous aiderait donc
passz passer faut leur dire passz passer
par Montini avant de passer par alors
certaines personnes viennent à la
journée mais d'autres dorment à la base
et jouent les Indiens notamment sous les
typis oui on a des camps atypiques donc
des des des camps reinçon sur les sous
les sous les tipis et on a des des camp
yourourt à la manière de de vie de des
mongoles et donc on y vient une nuit 3
nuits 5 nuits famille groupe donc ça
c'est très apprécier c'est déjà tout
tout plein tout plein donc en fait c'est
l'aventure à 5 en Eveline voilà c'est ça
donc de multiples façons de passer un
été agréable il faut aussi rappeler que
l'entrée est gratuite pour les les
résidents de 50 ans en Yveline ouais il
suffit simplement d'aller chercher sa
carte auprès de la mairie avec un
justificatif de domicile et sa carte
grise et on obtient une carte pour toute
l'année merci beaucoup Frédéric Bordier
rien et puis avant de se quitter on va
regarder Maxime l qui a donc testé la
vague de surf pour nous ah voilà très
bien surfing USA disait les Beach Boys
et bien moi aujourd'hui je vous propose
de surfing la base de loisir vous allez
voir c'est tout aussi sympa cette année
encore un simulateur de surf a été
installé on y a ajouté une vague
artificielle ça s'appelle le Wave
surfing mais alors qu'est-ce que c'est
que ce wave surfing une petite
explication ça pose c'est parti ça
USA
bonjour maamin bonjour Comment ça va ça
va et toi merci alors là tu es sur une
machine donc c'est le W surfer mobile
donc le fonctionnement c'est que tu as
une une pompe qui va injecter à forte
pression de l'eau donc tu vois là tu as
des bonnes vagues déjà tu vas avoir des
très bonnes sensations je te le garanti
faut vraiment pas avoir peur de toute
façon tu vas le sentir quand tu vas
faire t première tes premières
sensations donc là la la première chose
si tu veux on va tester sur le bodyurf
je pense que le mieux ça va être ça donc
tu vois tu prends tu prends ta planche
comme ceci donc les coup dans 90 comme
ceci on se lance un genou comme ceci
d'accord et en fait le but c'est de
lancer la planche au niveau de la vague
bon ben je crois qu'il est temps de
tester alors c'est parti on y va allez
on y va ça y est plus moyen de faire
demi-tour dernier conseil de Benjamin et
c'est partiie 2
3 ça c'est
bien des débuts difficiles j'enchaîne
les chutes mais je finis par trouver mon
équilibre enfin presque
voil donc vous l'avez compris pas besoin
de savoir faire du sur pour profiter de
cet engin vraiment particulier moi je
connaissais pas du tout et j'ai tout de
suite pris mon pied on peut le le dire
alors Benjamin est-ce que tu peux nous
rappeler de quand à quand est-ce qu'on
peut profiter de cet engin à la base de
loisir alors l'ouverture de cet engin
comme tu dis c'est du 7 juillet au 2
septembre il y a un coup 5 € les 15
minutes possibilité de venir en groupe
il y a la possibilité d'avoir deux
personnes qui font la vague en même
temps et là je peux te dire c'est encore
d'autres sensations mais j'ai vu que
tuéis très bien débrouillé en tout cas
voilà tout de suite on retrouve Alice
qui va nous faire une démonstration
toute autre c'est une démonstration
la journée d'un facogniier comment
devenir faconier qu'on va découvrir avec
Alice à
vousice